>> Fantastic. The solution for this is pretty straight forward, based upon what
we've already seen. Firstly, we walk through all the tile set's inside of the
map object that we've created. For each one of them, we've created a new image,
set it's on load function, and then set it's source name. Once we are loaded,
effectively we increment the imgLoadCount variable, and then we test if the
imgLoadCount variable is equal to the number of tile sets that could potentially
occur. So effectively, we are saying that our number of images loaded equal to
number of images that exist. If so, we can set fully loaded to true. Now, you'll
notice one annoying little variants of the JSON format for tiled, is that the
image path is actually an absolute path to the file from where the editor and
base file were formed. So effectively, what this is saying is that, given the
path to tiled, there's some really crazy file path to actually get to the grid's
master PNG from the source file we're using. So, to properly load that, what
we'd like to do is strip out all of the other data that's not just the file
name. And then, append the file name to our data directory. Now, this is because
our editing environment may be in a different directory structure than our
production environment that users are actually playing. For grids, we use this
nifty little regular expression here that allowed us to replace all of the data
before the final slash with blank characters, giving us the file name for this
image. We appended that filename to the ../data directory, giving us the source.